my early work was the breakthrough which
is probably as famous as this this was
given boy this with a magnetic resonance
and there's a create an equation named
after me is called the carpus equation
and so my life has been a combination of
breakthroughs about the might every five
years or so and maybe this will come up
later again I try to do something new
and so I've had breakthroughs at various
times during my life and what was
selected for the Nobel Prize is pretty
arbitrary and so it's a little hard to
say that what was the breakthrough I
mean what they cite actually is
something that I personally don't think
with a breakthrough but it's sort of a
little part of the important aspect of
what I and now many thousands of people
who use the same methods have done